this is the big national story we have
this from cnn politics the button
administration has declared monkey pox a
public health emergency
uh-oh the announcement came during a
briefing with the department of health
and human services the administration
has been criticized at times for its
handling of the outbreak since the first
u.s monkey pox case was identified
mid-may more than 6 600 probable or
confirmed cases have been detected in
the united states cases have been
identified in every state except montana
and wyoming
the declaration follows the world health
organization announcement last month
that monkey pox is a public health
emergency of international concern the
who defines a public health emergency of
international concern as an
extraordinary event that constitutes a
public health risk to other states
through the intention through the
international spread of disease and to
potentially require a coordinated
international response
okay well
look according to i think it's the world
health organization
95
of those who have been infected have
been men who have sex with men
and so there was a story where they were
saying you know
actually i'll just put it this way in
new york city if you want to get a
vaccine in order to be eligible you have
to be a a man who a male who has
intercourse with males and have had
multiple anonymous partners that's how
you qualify for the vaccine they're not
just giving this vaccine to anybody they
also said male identifying so really i
guess women can get the monkey pox
vaccine too
as long as you're claiming to
get with a bunch of guys i guess dude
that's like a struggle session they're
like you know what you got to do if you
want the vaccine
here's our guidelines go get them super
base that montana and wyoming don't have
it
i mean why do you think all the
californians want to move there yeah but
it's it's not so much that it's super
base like
i i drove through wyoming and i thought
i was gonna run out of gas
because i'm driving down this highway
for like 200 miles and it's just road
and then
there was this small shed looking
building and i'm like i got like 50
miles left in the tank and i'm driving
and then my friend goes look
and there's two there's two gas pumps
that i couldn't even tell were gas pumps
and i was like whoa and then we pulled
over immediately and it was like this
dude in his house with like a little dog
walking around and he had gas
and i was like well okay so yeah it's
really hard to transmit diseases in
environments like that beautiful though
very very pointed out that 95 at least
is the number i've heard of them is it
sounds like it's an std trans
transmitted by guys having sex with guys
it's not an std that's a very important
distinction
people have been saying that because of
what they're reporting it's just that
for obvious reasons
people who have multiple anonymous
partners they're touching each other a
lot and they're sharing bodily fluids a
lot so there's a higher higher
propensity to bro i guess that's true
because the common cold isn't an std and
you could get it by having sex with
someone and if you go and shake the hand
of somebody who's got it and then you
get it you're going to be like i swear i
wasn't going so is it because it's it's
not a blood disease it's a skin-to-skin
contact disease that it's not considered
an std yeah well it's not an std i want
to point out that just because someone
declares something doesn't mean that
it's actually real like i declare this
piece of obsidian is blue it's still
black uh so that they're
well hold on i mean he's saying it's an
emergency like that but that opens up
the fda we're talking about this before
the show to start making met approving
medicine for emergency authorized use
without proper testing channels if it's
considered an
emergency yeah yeah so i mean the the
phe being declared does
does open the door for
for medications vaccines other testing
diagnostics to
be
brought onto the market through
instead of going through the traditional
fda approval process through the
abbreviated eua process the emergency
use authorization process what bothers
me the most is that we've been softened
i think people have been softened to
what it means a medical emergency
actually is since covid like that people
are willing to
pretend that this might actually be a
real emergency i mean it might be a real
emergency well might is a different
story now i'm okay well
i'm saying in my opinion like the
reality is the government has declared
it so they're claiming it is my point is
people can get monkey pox from touching
other people and so while it's spreading
predominantly among
one particular group
it could find its way if people don't
take it seriously into general
population
like regular people will start popping
up like how did this happen and then all
of a sudden you got bumps or whatever
there's some crazy post on social media
where they're like if you're going to a
kink event just put band-aids over your
bumps
it's like well that's why it's spreading
so
i don't know man i don't know what
they're going to do
this is a little unrelated same thing
was going on in arizona it's taken two
days to count this vote in 2020 for the
first time it takes days to count votes
and people have been softened to it it's
like it happened in 2018. so it's but
it's a pretty new phenomenon where it's
taking multiple days to count a city's
votes well it's not and also 2000
maybe yeah and that was like well yeah
the recounts right right so it has
happened but like
i don't want to see people get like
like muted to the the what a real
emergency is because we keep being told
that we're in a state of emergency
we've we've like i don't think we've
ever not been in a state of emergency
our entire life since since september
11th 2001 it's been an emergency every
day
even before i love this country but it's
there's there's how many emergencies are
currently and are currently active in
the united states
it's there's there's probably dozens
because they they never just end them
they're like oh yeah 911 emergency and
then they just leave it
and then it's an emergency and then they
can do all this crazy stuff and it's
it's uh threatening to our liberties
right it's
a constant state of emergency as we saw
in with the in many ways unprecedented
restrictions on individual freedom
that happened in this country during the
covet 19 pandemic during the phe more
than 30 national emergencies remain in
effect wow what's the oldest one so they
say the legislation was signed by
president gerald ford on september 14th
1976 as of march 2020 60 national
emergencies have been declared more than
30 of which remain in uh in effect
so uh you know we're just sitting there
okay there's uh 42 currently in effect
we have them let's take a look list of
national emergencies in the united
states
all right let's see we got 42 still in
effect look at this liz it's huge let's
go all the way down
all right under biden you've got a
security emergency invocation of
emergency authority relating to
regulation of the anchorage and movement
of russian affiliated vessels to united
states ports
and we got this one uh biden protecting
certain property of
afghanistan bank
duh
for the benefit of the people of
afghanistan
you've got sanctions
you've got sanctions sanctions sanctions
sanctions you got trump trump's
emergencies are still in effect current
current current
so this one ended under trump here's a
current trump one declaring a national
emergency concerning the novel
coronavirus okay that we understand um
blocking property and suspending entry
of certain persons contributing to the
situation in syria
let's go back pre-trial let's go to
obama here's a current obama one
blocking property relating to venezuela
you've got uh uh central african
republic i mean these are all
emergencies man a lot of them are
sanctions a lot of them are sanctions
geez like 90 of them public health
underground sanctions yeah that was h1n1
is that still so the green ones are
still going on a lot of sayings it's
like all sanctions basically to be fair
legal what's that one legal protecting
the development fund for iraq and
certain other property in which iraq has
interest what does that mean
it's an emergency we got to make sure
that the iraqis get their land what the
heck is going on
dude that's been in effect since 2003
wow that's a george bush emergency there
crazy dude h1n1 isn't current right no
no i mean i think it's still it's still
around and stuff under bush at a trade
august 17th 2000 continuation of export
regulations and emergency declared okay
it's not an emergency anymore iraq's
taken care of we're not even our troops
are pulled out like no they still yeah
we're still technically we're supposed
to have by now but
arms current proliferation of weapons of
mass destruction emergency under bill
clinton 1994. what does that mean i mean
obviously it's a summary but what is
that oh here we go trading carter
sanctions still in effect blocking
iranian government property that's not a
surprise okay you know what i'll say
this i get it it's mostly sanctions i
understand but there's like seizure
under biden the people of afghanistan or
whatever the emergency declarations give
them just like blanket powers to do a
bunch of crazy stuff yeah and we saw
that on full display during the covet 19
pandemic unprecedented restrictions on
individual freedom lockdowns people in
my home state of north carolina a legal
state of the legal state of play was if
you didn't have a reason
to be out of your house
if you weren't going to the grocery
store or trying to get medical care then
you could be held liable for a criminal
misdemeanor you see that video of that
lady who owned the restaurant
and she set up an outdoor seating area
and then california shut it down but
right next to it was a movie production
company's outdoor spring area that was
up and running yeah she was crying
making a video about it because it
destroyed her business
you will own nothing and you will be
happy i heard from so many people in
2020 as this was starting people who
had invested their livelihoods into
starting businesses
in my home state and
they were completely devastated by the
restrictions and by the lockdowns and
then you had ppp money that was being
supposed to go to these people and one
of the dirty little secrets of the legal
profession is a lot of that money i can
tell you went to law firms
in in 2020 and 2021
and law firms by the way that never
locked down or shut down and and as i
came back into private practice learned
many of them had record years in 2020 so
oh good right so
wow
well well yeah and and and you know i
mean i'll speak to this as somewhat of a
traitor to my class but it's disgraceful
that working class men and women
who that money was really there for to
keep
to keep them uh
making ends meet
you know we're losing their livelihoods
while partners and in mid-sized law
firms were paying down their beach
houses that's a disgrace i'm sorry i
said a crazy thought
what if the elites
the wealthy are trying to strangle out
the working class
then
fund
advocacy for communism
by going to the working class and being
like man your life sucks like communism
look at this you know
well yeah yeah that's probably
yeah and then these people old ancient
practice strip people of their needs and
then promised to give them back yeah
yeah what was it what was it uh fast and
furious four i think it was
the villain in that in that uh movie it
was brilliant he was like
he was like giving uh he was helping the
locals giving him stuff and he was like
if you give them something then they
fear having it taken away and then
they're slaves or something like that so
it's kind of like
take people who are in in in dire
straits and give them just enough and
then you can threaten to take away what
very little they have we've got to get
back to
viewing the federal government as
something that we are allowing to exist
it's basically a union that we as uh
citizens of our states are allowing to
function it's not contr there to control
us it's there because we want it to be
there it doesn't have authority over us
we are it it is part of us and it's
supposed to work in synergy with us to
make sure that no one state goes rogue
and starts destroying its citizenry
that's basically the function of the fed
federal government
and and yet we have a very powerful as
we all know uh central government that
that really regulates
all aspects in many ways of our lives
right or at least if you're in a
commercial endeavor of any kind alphabet
suit of agencies and red tape and
regulations and all that comes with it
the professional class that's around it
the consultants
the
lobbyists and yes the lawyers that that
are are a part of that ecosystem right
um so yeah i mean the original intent of
the republic
as you as you pointed out right
a limited federal government with most
of the powers being
reserved to the states and to the people
where they could act locally and
uh and govern themselves thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and we'll
see you all there
you